hallo ich heiße angesprüht schweiz spiel
gegen albanien
deshalb haben die liebe ja bin ich froh
macht dann du bist bist du schlussspurt
[Musik]
wie wenig sie und so was bin ich
eigentlich die positiv entwickle ich
möchte dir eine junge leute haben dass
sie halt sie mir zur brust nehmen dass
ich ihn sagte häkkinen umgangs wurden
oder im verhalten straßen das andere
eher hamann ist der chef des
quartierladen sind surfer multikulti
vierter genau
[Musik]
gut ist für hans laven kann man lernen
wie erfolgreicher integration gibt
was ist das für eine dem gelingt was
anders gescheitert
und was für werte will er an jung und
alt weiter geben
[Musik]
handels dieser film
bitte die pflanzen aus dem zentrum für
ist einfach toll ganz damit kriegen
könnt runde schlaf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fertig ist die theorie vom partner
geboren du brauchst du weniger aber ich
bin mir aus spitze ich stelle fest sein
perfekt organisierter laden ist der
beste beweis dafür
die geschäftsprinzipien des
eingebürgerten schweizer center frischen
tat modisch ich bin auf dem land
aufgewachsen da ist man halt für einen
tag sie hat an romy gekommen ich habe
mal die tasche treibt bis zu jeder
highlight das sind für mich in samarra
kürzlich das dazu und das versuche der
schüler davids bringen
der laden von erhan steht in der grünau
einem quartier am stadtrand von zürich
noch vor ein paar jahren galt diese
gegend als problemviertel und noch immer
ist der ausländeranteil weit über dem
schweizer durchschnitt
hier hat er hermann einen mikro
aufgebaut
im auftrag der migros auf eigene
rechnung
ausgerichtet ihr wollt ihr beweisen was
er als geschäftsmann taugt sterne
quartier zumute projekten hat europa
problem hat der autobauer ford und sagen
abgeschottet für sie das ganze die
schwierige situation was volkswagen
animierten dazu passt dass ich seit dem
morgen geschafft dass ich finde eines
seiner erfolgsrezepte die leute vor ort
mit einbinden
immer wieder ist der vorplatz seines
ladens schauplatz für besondere anlässe
kulturen prallen aufeinander
[Musik]
wie viele russland abermals das ist
schon das problem der könnt ganz so
höher und damit 1 ist ein buch mit dem
tt rs schützen machen dass nicht weniger
also ganz sicher gegensätze vereinen für
den muslimen er habe anscheinend keine
sache von der kämpfer ali also alle die
wüste wird also er uns alle vier tiere
kennen das heißt du kennt charlene oder
sogar lauter mit dem sitzen darin
erlaubnis für ihre werte das papier
fürs quartier ist er hans laden innert
kurzer zeit zum treffpunkt geworden mit
den lehrlingen beginnt die
integrationsarbeit immer wieder von
vorne
das unbewusste ich denke das ist
seligkeit das machen wir also schlicht
darum wo sich park will ich froh bin
dass ich sie haben und mit denen der
zahn mannschaft du musst mir ins büro
mache die erlös liebte das bei vielen
von er hans lehrlingen ist es im leben
oft schief gelaufen
jamil ex zum beispiel fand keine
lehrstelle letztes jahr fiel sie durch
die prüfungen nun versucht sich noch
einmal und das ist ein problem schüler
er kam als jugendliche mit dem gesetz in
konflikt hat die lehre als bäcker
abgebrochen
jetzt mit 24 jahren steht er kurz vor
seinem ersten lehrabschluss im
detailhandel
wo es mache er hans ehrgeiz ist dass
diese beiden die prüfungen bestehen
ich stelle fest dass das viel
kleinarbeit im alltag bedeutet
minute
ich weiß man's folge lassen
[Musik]
das jamil ex trotz der warnungen und der
unterstützung des chefs zu wenig lernt
wurde er vor einem jahr zum verhängnis
man lernt auch lea die erst in einem
jahr abschließt ist bereits einmal
gescheitert in einem anderen betrieb
auch ihr hat er an noch einmal eine
chance gegeben haben
ausgestellte streit assist austragen
aber es geht auseinander so wie wenn man
bis zur prüfungsvorbereitung mit dem
chef
das gibt's regelmäßig in der gruppe oder
einzeln
wenn ich beurteile müssen auch über
hinaus lernen die vision das sage ich
nein die lehren wird nicht bestanden
wird und warum das weiß er selber ist
der historische ort wenn ich sage
brieflich zuordnen zu können
prüfungsnote zu kontrollieren
denn ist im heim ist noch nicht da sind
drei siegen über die schuhe ist das herz
der kritik
ich glaube er sich als druckmittel
verdienen und die märkte grad bis jetzt
dass es nach sowie geworden dass man ist
solange also kündigt würden hätten wir
sicher dass das mit vorrang
ich meine nein dazu sind sie leider
fehlen iaca doch so kostete
das hat mich auch gruppe also lücke
geben
nein denn das ist ja wieso also er hat
einige sachen falsch gemacht aber
ehrlich immer gerade dazu gestanden sagt
lukas und daran gemacht aber durch
miralles und ihnen das vertrauen drei
jahre arbeit mit hami neigen sich dem
ende zu
das ganze muss immer auf ihr blatt für
blatt sorger
ich habe mein coach wechselt aus
externer wurde ihm wird der waaler dort
stehen mit einer zeichen werde das nicht
zu machen
das konnte ich in den maxime wird durch
in der stunde fertig sind ist das mit
controlling kontron zum kopierer
kontrollfahrt wo zum beispiel sage jetzt
mal in die schule wenig aufpasst hat
oder einige fehler gemacht hat und sich
im nachhinein bewusst ist dass er fehler
gemacht hat habe ich mir sicher größere
chance will wenn ich deine jungen am
monatg chance geben woran zu chancen
auch er habe es nicht immer nur einfach
gehabt im detailhandel groß geworden
schafft er es bis ins mikro marketing
dann entschied sich wieder für die
basisarbeit um mit jungen leuten zu
arbeiten die er oft nicht aus
privilegierten verhältnissen stammen
[Musik]
der türken buwog saß älteste von drei
blüten im glarnerland auf die eltern
arbeiteten beide vollzeit in der
textilindustrie die buben oft auf sich
allein gestellt
er hat daheim in seinen vier wänden
ich erfahre dass seine mutter seit
einiger zeit bei ihm wohnt der vater
lebe mehrheitlich in der türkei als
ältestes sei es seine aufgabe die
familie zu unterstützen sagte er habe
glaub' ich war sie in ruhe miteinander
was sich oft die heute -nachrichten das
gupta ist ja schon gut aber es warte
wahren highlight in nächster zeit also
wenn ein highlight sind die aussehen
also münchen sich jetzt was er heiratet
aber nicht
er muss halt bloß ein wenig denn zu
der mann scheint schon immer eigene wege
gegangen zu sein als junger soldat hatte
der svp bei um als vorzeige migrant
aktiv in der partei tätig zu sein als
mit der schäfchen kampagne auf ausländer
gezielt wurde habe den austritt befindet
formulieren aber bisher demokratie
formuliere und das provokative hat nicht
verletzt
das gedankengut der svp ist ihm aber
weiterhin seine botschaft die werte der
schweiz aufrecht erhalten und ausländer
integrieren
da sieht er auch in der eigenen familie
handlungsbedarf werden die kooperative
technologien schuster sagte diesmal
mirwais ist vier jahre wie sie muss
vorschläge auf die hp mit dem
s-bahn-fahrer das hat sich wohl bekannt
wieso unerkannt willst du mont
ermöglicht hat du kannst du machst du
sollst wirtschaft ist das so und jetzt
ist ich sage du schauen was passiert
ich passiere sei bestünde kein kommando
alles sein
[Musik]
gott
bitte integration aller erhan scheint
vor allem auch zu heißen aktive
beziehungspflege haben gesagt stress
jetzt hier gelangen sie den ihnen
verfolgt next topmodel nutzer ich finde
du vorne bis einfach das heißt mehr
getraut sich des pbc das was natürlich
darf in delhi fühlt und sich nicht
getraut mir ich könnte ihn immer noch
sagen willst du mir lieber wenn sie
sagen oder sollte naja also jetzt besser
mit
was hat sich dann ganz für die sitze
sind viel mehr vertrauen
ich persönlich habe ich wusste ja
die abschlussprüfungen sind vorbei - und
hamm ii warten aufs resultat draußen
erfahre ich von a wie weit der chef
wirklich geht mit der unterstützung und
zwar nicht nur im schulischen bereich
ist mit den wings dann das wäre so
zeigen und dann stehst du sagt denecke
[Musik]
rückzug in die moschee wann immer
möglich geht er hin zum freitagsgebet
es beruhigt und das wollte ich
eigentlich aus dem ganzen alltag das so
dass ich bewusst wesentliche
konzentrieren
warum ich meine wenn ich das
praktizieren dass man ihnen gefordert
dass ich mich beruhigt viele dass wenn
ich als geschäftsrückgang viel lockerer
um ihn leichter stress abbaut
[Musik]
die besinnlichkeit radikalen islam geht
für den gar nichts
er halte es mit den grundsätzen der
religion
charlie seine brüder sind zu besuch
die familienbande sind sehr eng einmal
in der woche trifft man sich zum essen
und auch vater schaban aus der türkei
schaltet sich regelmäßig zu
[Musik]
obwohl da geboren und aufgewachsen ist
der bezug zur schweiz für alle blüten
anders
obwohl es war irgendwie sitzt muss immer
wieder dritter wurde ein türkei aber
starben
er war nicht alle verlage dann so
verdienen
was passiert finde ich auch die anderen
alan findest du hast du vorteil dass die
zwei verschiedene kulturgut buch sowie
was unterscheidet infobox aber ich würde
ja noch türkei und der schweiz ist das
pflicht erfüllt der besonders ich bin
also schön dass ich zwei kulturen
aufwachsen wenn das sie weine seien
sowohl südländisch also sollte ich da
mit dem temperament impulsiver
[Musik]
der große tag von jamil ex und haben
[Applaus]
die beiden haben bestanden
ich glaube dass du dir alles gute
ständig darüber hinaus haben auch als
kritisch
april hätten sie nimmerland richtigen
stelle zu den vorreitern
na ja bevor du bist nun lernen sie auf
einer säule mache jetzt bestellen was
ich die szene war
[Musik]
ambitioniert aber machbar
harry wird eine stelle finden ja wilex
nicht denn was wir da noch nicht wissen
die 21 jährige ist schwanger
bis das kind zur welt kommt kann sie im
laden von eran bleiben und er möchte ein
weiteres geschäft eröffnen und noch mehr
lehrlinge beschäftigen um kraft seines
vorbildes wirken zu können
[Musik]